good morning reg how are you good
morning theorem before we get to the
fireworks last night in staples between
the rockets and the Clippers I do not
care what any of those Dan nets are
saying I would personally rock that
shirt that is a nice-looking shirt and
the combo with the jeans and in tennis
shoes I like the outfit so don't listen
to the damn s so if someone's giving you
grief on that shirt they're not a true
fashionista I like it you want me to
hook you up with one on you I like that
alright alright okay alright cuz I've
seen you wear some outfits when we've
been out in LA a lot of vests like
there's certain things that look really
good on you that wouldn't look good on
me so I understand what you're saying
yeah more custom-made for you can you
buy off in it do you have to have
everything custom-made everything that's
custom in suits but you know every day
where I could I could I could find
things all right let me let me talk
about what happened last night during
the game and what led to whatever
happened after the game and were you
aware that there were stuff going on
after the game after the game no I
didn't hear about that till I got home
and turned on our postgame show and
heard Charles and Shaq kind of laughing
about it about the police presence being
called to the locker room so we didn't
hear about it immediately afterwards
obviously we were in our cars heading
back but you could kind of see things
going on throughout the game especially
be talking between Chris and Blake which
I thought was more genuinely fun because
after a little shove or elbow here they
would both kind of grimace or smile so I
just thought they were having fun with
one another but it took a turn when the
benches started to kind of draw at one
another Austin Rivers Patrick Beverley
who were in there
civvies and we're talking all night to
Chris Paul and the rest of the Rockettes
I think that kind of ignited what was
kind of going on on the floor but
personally I loved it I said this on air
last night I'm tired of the whole
hugging it out and let's go have a beer
afterwards the generation this was an
old school feel to it there's no love
lost between these two teams we know
about the big trade that happened
bringing Chris Paul to the Rockets the
Clippers got I thought a boatload of
young talent and there was some cheap
meanness between the two this is twice
now that the Clippers have gotten
Houston the Houston Rockets I know one
Chris Paul didn't play in the first
matchup but it was it was pretty fiery
last night yeah rich how how does the
NBA react to this because I said I drop
a financial bomb on certainly the
Rockets for going into or trying to get
to the Clippers locker room absolutely
there's no excuse for that again this is
being reported we don't know for sure
but you know I heard Loco
say this so obviously you and I we
weren't there but if it is reported that
they were actually worth trying to get
into the locker room not only could
there be a hefty fine you may even be
looking at suspensions just so something
like this never happens again because
you can't be trying to go search and
locate someone that you have beef with
afterwards I mean we kind of saw this a
couple days ago between bin Simmons and
Kyle Lowry from Toronto when they kind
of got into it and both got thrown out
and you know Simmons was motioning him
hey meet me in the back
Academy of reminiscence of that fight
between Rick Fox and Doug Christie if
you remember years back in that game
between the the Sacramento Kings and the
Los Angeles Lakers when they have you
know they both got tossed out and they
kind of got into a scuffle in the back
hallway so you can't have this I would
not be surprised as you had mentioned a
hefty fine and possible suspensions just
so no one else has the idea of doing
something like this when they get into a
scuffle were you ever involved in
anything like that that somebody came to
your locker room or
your guys went to somebody else's locker
room no we never went to no we handle
things on the floor
that's we had your fights and your balls
on the floor you never took it into the
locker room no one ever tried to get
into our locker room we never went and
try to get into lock look they play
again February 28th
so what you know why try to get them in
the back locker room you're gonna play
them at least two more times and you
know if both teams continue to play well
possibly in the playoffs handle it on
the floor so we all can see what is the
label on Chris Paul look to me first
ballot hall-of-famer
but at times he could rub people the
wrong way because you know I called him
a basketball savant because he lives
breathes and dies basketball from
watching it obviously playing it he is
so immersed it in and at times it could
rub people the wrong way because some
people are not all committed like Chris
is and I think at times that rubbed some
of his teammates with the Clippers the
wrong way in particular Blake Griffin
and you could kind of see there I think
there they were cool they were cordial
towards one another but it was a little
frosty I was surprised they didn't
release fist bump before the tip you
know there was nothing no so I mean
these two were the face of the franchise
with six great years I mean they had a
win percentage of 66% and 550 win season
together so that's something to be proud
of for the Los Angeles Clippers who were
always the doormat of the NBA so
something to be proud of and I was just
surprised they didn't at least show a
little bit of love towards one another
Reggie has 76ers Celtics coming up
Thursday night 7:00 Eastern on TNT I'm
watching the Cavs last night and it
dawned on me that maybe this is the last
time we see this great rivalry play out
between these two teams
given the current rosters of you know in
LeBron bein in Cleveland I mean it just
sort of hit me like I don't know if
LeBron is gonna be back I don't know if
they're gonna get to the finals and
maybe this is the last time we see these
two go head to head these two teams in
the current makeup here and my thought
was red at
some point over the next couple of weeks
I would just say to LeBron I'm more than
happy to trade that number one pick and
I'll trade Tristan Thompson and we could
get DeAndre Jordan and all of a sudden
I've changed the entire defensive
complexion of this team and makes us
legitimate but I need an insurance
assurance from you that you're going to
stay if I make this deal do you think
you could see a scenario play out like
that I do not
I just don't think LeBron is gonna give
up his cards like that and if he hasn't
told him already that he's staying or
he's committed then he's not going to
but there is on him reg that I'm not
gonna make a deal right no I wouldn't I
would hold on to that no because you
possibly could have the next LeBron
James and that number one pick look I
think it's not up to LeBron to alert the
Cavaliers if he wants to stay or not
it's a business at the end of the day I
mean he's been great for the bottom line
to Dan Gilbert in the Cleveland
Cavaliers organization I mean every game
is sold out and three straight trips to
the NBA Finals winning one of them so
he's been great to their bottom line he
has to worry about his bottom line as
well it's not up to him to appease the
Cavaliers we've seen this in history of
him taking his talents elsewhere so
right now he's gonna try in my opinion
to put them in the best position to me I
know everyone's saying there's a crack
in the kingdom but I think this
four-game stretch where they were
absolutely embarrassed embarrassed in
Minnesota embarrassed in Toronto
embarrassed by the Pacers by having a
big twenty one point lead and getting
locked down and then on national TV
again the world champs come in and made
it look kind of easy they made it look
real easy so I think this wargames
stretch of these embarrassing games
could be a wake-up call to me it's still
gonna be very difficult in the East for
a team to beat that dude four times with
no back to back and you can lock in I
know people think there's you know
there's a big huge foundation crack for
the Cavaliers but at the end the day
you've got to beat LeBron four times and
it's going to be
me I just think it's very difficult to
do that in the eastern comp
you don't think Boston can beat him four
times having home court advantage I I do
not I don't as well as they're playing I
just don't see it because you're I know
what Kyrie can do but I'm asking a lot
from two young players in Jalen Brown
and Jason Tatum to be special and
they've been that during the regular
season but as you know Daniel once the
playoffs begin and if you talk about
them matching up in the Eastern
Conference Finals that's a lot of
pressure to put on a 21 and a 22 year
old going against a generational type
player and LeBron James no don't get me
wrong it could happen but with no back
to backs and a chance for teams to lock
in on you I mean you've got to beat the
dudes four times and I just don't see
the Easter copper's team doing that you
had strong comments last week calling
out the Lakers in what they should do
with Lavar ball and I'm curious what the
the reaction was because he got picked
up by a lot of people and and I know
that we try not to talk acknowledged
Lavar but we do acknowledge Lonzo since
he's an actual player but what was the
reaction you got and did anybody from
the Lakers react to that I have not
heard anything no one reached out to me
but one thing I did kind of want to
piggyback on our conversation last week
I hope people don't think that I am
talking noise to any of those three
young men because I love the bald
brothers I think they're fantastic all
my comments are directed towards pops I
have no problem with Lonzo D'Angelo
lamella i think they're going to be
fabulous players I don't think the the
other two are going to make the NBA so
but I don't think I hope people don't
think the comments were directed toward
to them because I just don't want I look
at those guys and how much pressure it
is to make the NBA in itself but when
you've got this outside influence that's
making it even difficult for you I
shouldn't say outside it's inside
Pop's it's not fair to to those kids to
have that much pressure at such a young
age to be prom playing a man's game in a
man's sport and they're just babies I
mean you took you
you took this dude out of high school
and it took them over to Lithuania come
on man I mean come on man
before I let you go are you on an
episode of Hell's Kitchen I am this
Friday Hell's Kitchen please people
tuned in it was an all-star shootout I'm
not gonna say who was wait who's I with
you did you get yelled at by Gordon
Ramsay I got yelled at Gordon Ramsay was
in my grill I was so petrified Ron
yelling at me hey forget about any of
these other coaches that screamed at me
when you got Gordon Ramsay yelling at
you in the kitchen you're gonna get
right I tell you this I'm not on a team
we had a one of the chef is my coach and
we had to cook a dish their favorite
dish you know in the opening show they
always have a signature dish the chef we
had to cook their signature dish with no
assistance from them they could just
like tell you what to do but I was good
with the ones and twos the knives and
forks so reg reg Thursday night as
seventy sixers of the Celtics at 7:00
Eastern on TNT and then Hell's Kitchen
on Friday night safe travels is always
reg thank you brother
these are you are truly the best my
friend na send me maybe an XXL a nut
shirt maybe an XXL I might rock it all
right all right you know we could do it
like twins
ya know Danny DeVito and Schwarzenegger
so the next time I'm in LA we could go
out to dinner and you could wear yours
and I could wear mine
[Laughter]
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]